[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans le
grand jt des territoires nouveaux grands
jt des territoires en pleine crise du
coc vide 19
vous le savez le confinement va durer le
premier ministre l'a annoncé devant
l'assemblée nationale cette semaine
certaines zones de france sont en
vacances de pâques et les autorités
craignent donc un relâchement des
français face aux mesures annoncées dans
certaines villes comme vous allez le
voir celle du mans par exemple la police
nationale utilise des drones de
surveillance pour repérer et dissuader
le regroupement de personnes
regardez ce reportage de nos confrères
de lmtv sartre sur place
[Musique]
c'est le type de message que vous
pourrez entendre dessus de vos têtes
dans les jours à venir
prêtez pas la police judiciaire de
rennes des drones viendront
régulièrement patrouiller sur le mans
j'ai constaté ces jours ci à certain
relâchement dans la population
quant au respect des règles du
confinement et donc nous allons durcir
les contrôles nous allons être plus
sévère et utiliser tous les moyens à
notre disposition dont les drones qui
sont une technologie qui permet d'aller
surveiller une aire beaucoup plus large
et notamment plus discrètement puisque à
la proche de tel ou tel endroit quand on
voit les services de police on peut
faire demi tour on peut essayer de
contourner les contrôles mais là avec le
drone c'est pas possible on est on est
surpris parce qu'il est en l'air le
drone peut monter jusqu'à 6000 mètres de
haut plus discret et qui permet
d'accéder plus facilement à certains
lieux comme les bois ou des parcs
ici un groupe de personnes vient d'être
repéré ouais vous faites intervenir là
on ratisse le petit bois et compléments
la formation d'un groupe composé d'une
dizaine d'individus commence dans un
premier temps par faire une patrouille
avec un premier drone pour repérer les
endroits où on peut avoir des groupes
qui ne respectent pas les mesures et
dans un second temps on en envoie un
deuxième drone qui lui est équipé d'un
haut-parleur et qui diffuse un message
de prévention qui incite les groupes a à
se disperser les gens à rentrer chez eux
et dans un troisième temps si on
constate que ce n'est pas suffisant et
si les groupes ne se disperse pas on
envoie des patrouilles de police et là
les personnes qui violent la loi seront
verbalisés contravention pour rappel qui
s'élève à 135 euros
plus d'un millier ont déjà été dressés
depuis le début du confinement
on va aussi puisque je parlais de
renforcement des contrôles durcir les
contrôles
al'approche des vacances scolaires c'est
à dire dès demain pour éviter pour faire
appliquer la mesure qui interdit de se
déplacer à l'occasion des vacances
scolaires le virus tue il faut en être
conscient
chaque jour plusieurs centaines de
personnes meurent parce qu'elles ont été
contaminées par le
virus qu'ovide 19 et donc il faut
vraiment que chacun prenne conscience de
sa responsabilité individuelle dans le
respect du confinement
voilà restait donc bien tous chez vous
car vous le savez nous allons bientôt
probablement être tous tester c'est la
question du moment un seul laboratoire
en france propose le test sérologique
pour dépister le colis de 19
il est situé en lorraine comment ça se
passe quelle fiabilité à ce test
alors que le conseil scientifique estime
qu'il est urgent d'attendre
sur ce sujet nous faisons le point dans
ce laboratoire de la ville de vittel
vous allez le voir avec les équipes de
vie à vos genoux partenaires sur place
rien ne préparait ce laboratoire
d'analysé à un tel bouleversement le 3
février il ouvre ses portes dans la
commune de sainte marguerite voisine de
celle de saint dié mais avec le
coronavirus le personnel voit très vite
la routine à peine trouver chamboulés
les conséquences
sont assez inattendu on s'attendait pas
à voir une changement d'activité si
brutale et demandent si différente un
peu du jour au lendemain presque en
l'espace de deux semaines du coup on
s'est réorganisé on a organisé un drive
pour les prélèvements chez les patients
qui sont concernés et qui ont un intérêt
à faire un prélèvement ce que vous
arranger bien parce que du coup l'ancien
ancien site c'était une ancienne
pizzeria donc le drive était finalement
des halles à la rs les autorise à
dépister le personnel de santé les
femmes enceintes et les personnes aux
pathologies chroniques pour prendre un
maximum de précautions les échanges avec
le patient se font le plus à distance
possible après le mans naso pharyngé
donc c'est relativement profond c'est 5
à 7 cm un premier temps donc c'est voir
avec le médecin traitant à médecin pour
avoir une ordonnance est donc dans un
deuxième temps nous appelait donc pour
qu'on puisse nous établir le dossier ici
et comprennent tous les renseignements
et donc dans un troisième temps on leur
donne rendez-vous et ont bâti restent à
l'extérieur du laboratoire les personnes
restent dans leur voiture les mesures
d'hygiène ont été renforcées sur blues
grand masque le laboratoire arrive pour
l'instant à obtenir le matériel
nécessaire en moyenne quatre personnes
seulement se présente pour ce type de
test chaque jour l'activité globale est
au ralenti vous me direz la presse à
tout mais ça fait pas mal constate
globalement ses ennemis son activité ce
qui est cohérent finalement des
prélèvements comme les chirurgies ont
été déprogrammés
et services d'oncologie se sont aussi un
peu arrangé on va parler et et les
urgences où les suivi classique continue
quand même mais on sent quand même qu'il
ya une diminution probablement un
décalage des éléments qui n'étaient pas
nécessaires nécessairement les analyses
que 8,19 sont fait normalement au sein
du groupement des laboratoires bio lia
mais en rupture de réactifs les
échantillons sont actuellement envoyés
sur paris il faut patienter 24 heures
pour les résultats dans le département
des drive tests ont également ouvert à
epinal remiremont gérardmer et vittel
voilà nous faisons à présent le point
sur l'état sanitaire dans les hôpitaux
avec une bonne nouvelle enfin les
chiffres d'admission au service de
réanimation et de soins intensifs se
sont stabilisées dans la région des
hauts de france notamment cependant vous
allez l'entendre de la part des
responsables du chu de lille il faut
maintenir les efforts notamment en
matière de confinement bien sur ce point
s'est tenu par visioconférence et une
première avec les équipes de la chaîne
ou et au new partenaires dans les hauts
de france regardez ce qu'on peut dire
c'est que l'augmentation du nombre de
cas est moins forte
là ces derniers jours donc en fait on a
une à une bande un qui monte qui monte
qui monte depuis des semaines est
actuellement mais là ces jours ci
l'augmentation du nombre de cas est
moins forte je crois qu'on peut pour
l'instant vraiment avec prudence s'en
tenir à ça la prudence est de mise quand
même parce que l'interprétation au jour
le jour dans mes pas d'avoir une vision
suffisamment globale pour tirer des
conclusions
l échelle de ce qui se pose en point de
vue épidémique
on a toujours autant de patients mais
depuis quelques jours ça a cessé
d'augmenter cette cette vente
voilà c'est de toute évidence les effets
du confinement et on est tous
s'inquiètent sur ce qui va se passer
le week-end prochain parce que le
week-end prochain sera très clairement
l'effet du week-end qui vient de se
passer on a tous vu que le week-end qui
vient de se passer nul n'a pas du tout
du tout du tout du tout respecté les
mesures de confinement dans un certain
nombre d'endroits et samedi dimanche
lundi les quelques jours qui arrivent
s'il se traduisent par une augmentation
de fréquence de vos services irs parce
qu'elle services d'urgence traduiront la
rupture du respect du confinement dans
le week-end qui vient de se passer tout
le corps médical et bien entendu vous le
savez complètement mobilisé et le site
d'information actus.fr nos confrères
nous apprend qu'à toulouse les étudiants
en médecine et en pharmacie ont créé un
site info sur l'épidémie sous l'égide de
plusieurs médecins de la ville rose ce
site regroupe des nombreuses
publications scientifiques ainsi que des
informations dédiées au grand public
avoué si vous souhaitez en savoir plus
et bien rendez vous sur le site de nos
confrères et partenaires d'actu point fr
comme vous le voyez sur cet écran les
soignants nous venons de le voir dans
divers reportages ont besoin de matériel
pour travailler bien sûr à présent nous
vous proposons une immersion dans un
centre logistique de santé le centre
logistique de santé grenoblois là où est
stocké l'ensemble du matériel nécessaire
aux soignants comme des masques par
exemple des gants si ou encore des
surblouse un lieu stratégique que nous
font visiter nos confrères de tv
grenoble sur place regarder
c'est l'un des enjeux majeurs au coeur
de cette crise sanitaire liée aux
qu'ovide 19 le matériel de protection
est une donnée essentielle pour le
personnel soignant au coeur de cette
période de confinement et c'est ici sur
cette plateforme de logistique et gérer
l'ensemble des stocks produits
dentretien dhygiène dispositifs médicaux
tout est regroupé avant d'être organisés
en commande pour les services de soins
avant d'être finalement envoyé sur les
différents sites du chu comme l'hôpital
nord à la tronche et l'hôpital sud à
echirolles et forcément le plus gros de
l'activité actuelle est rythmée par la
pandémie de corona violent au niveau des
masques
on est l'action de l'état a fonctionné
aujourd'hui on a de quoi avoir quelques
jours devant nous au niveau des stocks
au niveau des masses sont capables
d'enjeux sur ces produits là il ya plus
de tension en tout cas comme il a pu en
avoir
début mars ou fin février les sur blues
on est là pour le coup on est en plein
dans le dans la crise où on a vraiment
du mal à se réapprovisionner
aujourd'hui nos principaux nos
principales subtilisation ça va être des
dons de bloscon fait avoir justement par
rapport aux appels à dons qu'on a pu
faire l'essai relais jours des dons qui
bifurquent aussi par cette plateforme
qui s'occupera de faire le tri et
l'analyse du matériel en question avant
de l'intégrer au stock global et si
l'activité générale a paradoxalement ici
quelque peu baissé depuis le début de la
crise les besoins des différents
services qui s'occupent des patients
infectés par le cos vide 19e exige une
mobilisation de tous les instants
concernant l'approvisionnement alors le
rythme tiens c'est vrai que comme je
vous disais une légère baisse d'activité
mais il ya certaines commandes qui sont
plus volumineuse donc ils demandent un
peu plus d'efforts physiques mais
l'équipe joue le jeu on est tous là pour
rendre service
au chu en général aux patients qui sont
amenés à être hospitalisée pour beaucoup
vide c'est vrai que les services de
soins font un travail énorme et
heureusement qu'ils sont là et
heureusement que nous les logisticiens
aussi participent à tous ces efforts
chaque jour ce sont ainsi plusieurs
camions qui font les allers retours
entre les hôpitaux de l'agglomération
grenobloise et cette plateforme de
logistique des convois de marchandises à
chaque fois rigoureusement escorté par
la gendarmerie
à l'heure où masques nous et les gels
hydroalcooliques sont au coeur de toutes
les conversations au sort les grandes
entreprises françaises également se
mobilisent contre ce virus du coc vide
19 le groupe pro notamment s'organisent
pour répondre aux besoins de matériel
médical plusieurs projets sont engagés
la production de visière pour le
personnel soignant et la participation à
la conception de respirateur artificiel
le technocentre de guyancourt dans les
yvelines participe activement à ces deux
missions comme le montre ce reportage de
nos construire sur place de tv 78 donc
dans les yvelines et de la recherche et
développement automobile à la production
de matériel médical
le technocentre renault de guyancourt
s'est adapté à la crise sanitaire du coc
vide 19
plus d'une centaine de collaborateurs de
ce site sont mobilisés sur plusieurs
projets notamment la production de
visière destiné au personnel soignant
on a l'ensemble de nous les laissons de
production par impression 3d qui sont
mobilisés pour produire des supports de
ville hier à destination des soignants
on dessine plutôt ces masques là pour
les filières là pour le personnel
soignant que c'est vraiment des matières
qui sont compatibles avec les protocoles
de désinfection 700 visière ont déjà été
produites sur les sites de guyancourt
flins et maubeuge depuis le début de la
semaine un moule a été conceptualisée
pour produire en grandes séries objectif
4000 visière minimum par semaine
c'est un moule qui permet de sortir une
pièce plastique avec une cadence très
élevée qu'on injecte en fait un
plastique
dans un moule en métal et dire pouvoir
sortir à la suite très rapidement donc
ça permet de passer ce pic en vins
primés en 3d sur une machine vous allez
pouvoir par exemple sur 24 heures sur
les sur des matières qui sont bio
compatible sortir 60 unités alors que là
on va pouvoir avoir une capacité une
vitesse de production bien supérieure et
en même temps linéaire et nos
imprimantes 3d pour la fabrication qui s
à destination des respirateurs c'est
l'autre activité du technocentre dans ce
contexte de crise sanitaire la
participation à la conception de
respirateurs à travers deux projets avec
un consortium industriel autour de
michelin du seuil de stmicroelectronics
et d'une initiative d'ingénieur à paris
sur ces deux projets là on apporte des
compétences en conception des
compétences achats des compétences
logistique supply chain réalisation
prototype également la partie les
industriels
le projet qu'elle puisse avancer
aujourd'hui on envisage une mise en
production vraiment sous autant avec une
production de 500 aspirateur joint donc
une part qu'il serait à réaliser pour
l'instant si ces études que nous avons
en cours au déconcentre cette situation
est inédite une véritable organisation
industrielle collaborative pour
participer à la lutte contre le
coronavirus
voilà les initiatives sympathique aussi
dans ce grand jt des territoires
direction la bretagne à présent de
nombreuses petites communes souhaite
revitaliser leur centre bourg et y
remettre un peu de lien social
c'est l'un des objectifs de l'épicerie
couleurs pays c'est son nom à plovan
avec le confinement cette enseigne 30
une toute autre dimension et fait office
de supérettes car le supermarché le plus
proche est situé à 8 km les gérantes
sont à la fois
assistante sociale livreuse de course à
domicile elles font tous les métiers
c'est un reportage dans le pays bigouden
de christophe bouchet pour la chaîne
tébéo la scène de nos confrères du
groupe le télégramme en bretagne
regardez entre terre et mer plovan dans
le pays bigouden compte 600 habitants et
possède un seul commerce couleurs pays
est tenu par les deux morgan depuis 2015
à l'heure du confinement les gérantes ne
chôme pas c'est là que devant les shops
et le téléphone chauffe jeu permet aussi
de tranches de jambon
d'accord je t'emmène savais que je peux
à tout alerté les anciens bas quand ils
leur arrivent des petites bricoles ou
qu'ils n'ont pas envie de bouger ils
nous appellent et puis ben là c'est
pareil c'est x 10 donc on va les emmener
du ps c'est bon pour les affaires mais
les clients viennent chercher autre
chose qu'un fruit tranches de jambon
encore du pain c'est l'animation de de
plovan et ça permet de faire du lien
social c'est vraiment indispensable à
une communauté comme ici car couleurs
pays c'était à la fois une épicerie un
bar une salle de danse et de cinéma mais
aussi de jeu et un lieu où l'on cherche
de la chaleur humaine activement ici que
notamment maintenant mais aussi
comprendre les nouvelles de tout le
monde qu'on sait ce qui se passe dit
tiens t'as pas vu t'as pas vu truc ça
comment ça va il a ouvert ses volets il
a pas ouvrir ses volets j'ai su qu'il
était malade
est-ce qu'il est rentré l'hôpital macha
sa voiture en panne comment il fait
voilà donc c'est aussi un petit peu
carrefour du village finalement ou où
tout se passait puis dans des périodes
comme ça va c est décuplée et les morgan
savent de quoi elle parle elle
travailler dans le social auparavant
mais à l'heure du confinement l'attitude
de certains est irrationnelle et prend
le dessus même lors des achats dans une
épicerie
c'est les listes de courses géante avec
des trucs un peu farfelu à mettre dessus
du chantier rue lentilles l'image des
bains de bouche la marque du ch a
préféré du ch à la loupe du chat
spécifique haute en couleur et
attachants les deux morgan participe à
redonner en ces périodes troubles un peu
d'âme et de bienveillance dans ces
bourgs qui en ont tant besoin en cette
période
nous quittons la bretagne pour nous
rendre à présent en haute savoie à
albertville avec cette initiative les
habitants peuvent désormais consommé
deux pays c'est eux des produits de
leurs producteurs locaux et les faire
livrer à domicile cela grâce à
l'initiative de quelques bénévoles du
secteur actuellement au chômage partiel
c'est sébastien germain et les équipes
de 8 mont blanc qui ont suivi la tournée
de camions vous allez le voir
pas tout à fait comme les autres bien
décidés à jouer leur rôle avec
professionnalisme les premiers bénévoles
du petit camion se tiennent prêts pour
eux c'est le grand jour
en une semaine pas moins d'une
cinquantaine de commandes ont été
passées sur le site internet
le pari est donc d'ores et déjà gagnée
pour le collectif
même si les choses sérieuses ne font que
commencer l'objectif est largement
atteint et puis le plus grand plaisir
c'est que les la majorité des gens qui
ont commandé sont dans la cible qu'on
s'était fixé au début c'est des gens qui
ne peuvent pas se déplacer c'est des
gens qui sont âgés qui sont fragiles qui
sont sensibles les quinon qui ont peur
de mettre les pieds dehors et c'est
normal on
de rester confinés c'est des gens qui ne
peuvent pas se déplacer il ya des gens
qui sont handicapés qui sont en fauteuil
il ya des gens qui sont gravement malade
et c'est ce qui a été le plus le plus
grisant parce que c'est d'avoir eu ces
gens téléphonent de se rendre compte que
le service qu'on a mis en place avec
acharnement avec une petite équipe de 15
personnes depuis une semaine il a
atteint l'objectif numéro un qu'on
s'était fixé c'est chouette mais avant
de partir honorer toutes les commandes
il faut déjà réceptionnés et trier
toutes les denrées fruits légumes
salaisons ou encore plantes potagères
arrivent petit à petit dans le local
qu'on voyait par les producteurs
eux-mêmes qui ont tout de suite été
séduit par le concept
comme il ya eu ce site qui a été créée
que c'était pour la soul et la
solidarité de pouvoir livrer un maximum
de personnes et nous aider à diminuer
nos stocks en fait parce que c'est quand
même assez compliqué à la pâtisserie
jouer à peu près dix clients par jour
donc je suis bien content d'avoir le
soutien du petit camion pour écouler
quelques petites poules et quelques
petits poissons restent encore à gérer
les petits problèmes a lié au lancement
d'une telle organisation
malgré cela le petit camion reste promis
à un bel avenir en effet en quelques
jours à peine plus d'une centaine de
bénévoles se sont fait connaître pour
prêter main forte à l'initiative locale
voilà les titres de la presse
quotidienne régionale également se
mobilisent durant cette crise du coc
vide 19 et regarder cette initiative du
quotidien sud ouest qui vient de lancer
une plateforme gratuite sur internet
course contre la montre point fr ça
s'appelle pour relancer l'activité des
producteurs des commerçants des artisans
ou des professionnels de tourisme de la
région touchée évidemment par cette
crise l'idée bien cette proposé soit des
livraisons soient des bons d'achat ou de
pré commande que les consommateurs
utiliseront à l'issue de la période de
confinement une façon aussi de les
soutenir
dominique parmentier pour la chaîne tv7
la chaîne du groupe sud ouest nous parle
de cette initiative regard des activités
touristiques à l'arrêt bars et commerces
fermés comme partout à bordeaux la place
caillou habituellement grouillantes de
monde à cette période est déserte
obligé de fermer brutalement ce biais
rist à la fois bar à bières et cave a
perdu 63 % de son chiffre d'affaires au
mois de mars
et même s'il pourra bénéficier dette de
l'état il essaie de compenser des pertes
en poursuivant les livraisons
à domicile d'abord via ses réseaux
sociaux il est l'un des premiers à
s'être inscrits sur la nouvelle
plateforme que vient de lancer sud ouest
alors cette nouvelle plateforme permet
d'avoir de la visibilité d'un rapport
aux gens qui connaissent pas forcément
la bière history elle permet de proposer
davantage d'options la dette déjà c'est
un site internet moi c'est juste un un
partage envoie un lien c'est un fichier
excel tout dette ya pas deux j'ai pas de
site de boutiques en ligne donc là ça
donne déjà il ya des photos etc
on peut parler un peu de ce qu'on fait
et puis proposer différentes la course
contre la montre ça fait partie des
nombreuses initiatives qui ont appris à
sud ouest pour continuer à être utile à
nos communautés locales tout simplement
sur notre territoire de la nouvelle
aquitaine course contre la montre c'est
une initiative solidaire pour venir en
aide aux producteurs aux commerçants aux
artisans pour soutenir leur trésorerie
pendant cette période difficile aussi
pour déstocker pour ceux qui en ont
besoin et donc c'est une plateforme
internet qui permet la mise en relation
entre des offres de producteurs
d'artisans de commerçants des bons
d'achat ou des produits
et puis des clients nos lecteurs une
plateforme gratuite qui s'adresse
également aux commerces autorisés à
ouvrir pendant cette période de
confinement mais qui souffre aussi
c'est le cas de ce marchand et
réparateur de vélos de la place
stalingrad qui a dû mettre ses deux
employés au chômage
à part quelques soignants ou autres
rares professionnels en activité il ne
voit quasiment aucun client il faut
reconnaître qu'on ne voit plus beaucoup
de vélo aujourd'hui dans les rues de
bordeaux
même sur le pont de pierre
méconnaissable normalement nous n'avons
pas droit au chômage partiel pour nos
salariés
sauf si on fait la démonstration que
malgré tous nos efforts possibles
nous avons une activité qui est réduite
quasiment à néant ce qui est le cas
alors cette plateforme
c'est un peu comme une bouée de
sauvetage l'intérêt pour le magasin bien
sûr c'est d'essayer de d'informer les
clients qui ont encore besoin de rouler
avec leurs vélos sur le fait que nous
sommes d'accord ouvert et qu'on peut les
dépanner essayer de capter encore un
type d'activité et puis surtout de
faciliter le redémarrage en donnant de
la visibilité supplémentaire à notre
notre magasin la plateforme permet en
effet de mettre en lien direct le
consommateur avec le fournisseur à ce
jour 250 enseignes se sont
déjà inscrites et le site enregistré
plus de 24000 session
voilà les problèmes de la presse
quotidienne régionale sont des problèmes
d'impression et de distribution c'est
également le cas pour la presse
nationale et la presse magazine
je reçois dans ce grand jt des
territoires georges ghosn éditeurs de
presse vous avez été propriétaire de
france soir notamment du nouvel
économiste vous l'êtes aujourd'hui de
vsd alors il ya eu beaucoup de problèmes
d'impression de distribution de la
presse ces derniers jours
quand at il était vraiment de ces
problèmes
dans cette longue crise qui commence à
durer du coronavirus legrand n'a
évidemment respecter énormément puisque
d'une part les relais qui lui représente
en gros 20 25% des ventes de quotidiens
et des magazines
j'ajoute arrêtés n'ont pas de gars pas
d'un aéroport etc
c'est un gros coup alors inversement les
grandes et moyennes surfaces gms comme
on les appelle dans le jargon ont
progressé puisque les gens vont faire
leurs courses pour cachette à ma fiche
de journaux
mais la fréquentation des kiosques est
catastrophique alma de cinq ans moins 50
à -60%
la plupart des grands qui t'ont fait
déjà des demandes de chômage technique
même les plus riches dire dans les
propriétaires sont élevées images comme
les échos le parisien
alors georges ghosn je le disais vous
êtes éditeur de presse
on sait que presstalis qui distribue les
journaux a connu des problèmes
financiers ces derniers mois comment ça
s'est passé précisément pendant cette
crise est ce que presstalis qui
distribue vos journaux a pu jouer son
rôle
presstalis a demandé aux clients quels
sont les mlp
ils sont meilleures formes sont plus
légers ils ont moins frais -
d'administration et terrain donc la
solution viendra probablement du côté
des mails paix puisque presstalis à mon
avis va être liquidée il n'y a pas
d'autre issue
il ya même pas un plan de continuation
possible puisqu'il ya en gros 50
millions à 100 millions de déficit
annuel c'est à dire que cette boîte part
entre 5 et 10 millions de personnes le
sait d'ailleurs par mois l'état finance
en gros à une trentaine de millions sans
compter ce qu'il donne quotidien par
exemple le monde est contre toute
réforme alors qu'ils ne vont plus que à
peine vingt mille exemplaires par jour
le monde dans le temps c'était 150 mille
aujourd'hui moi j'ai eu françois 150000
aujourd'hui ville
donc c'est ridicule en revanche le monde
numérique vend 150 milles
mais avant ils ont tellement de
subventions dumiste à la culture qui
aident et qui elle aussi presstalis que
sa fille à papa le coup mais ce prix
devrait durer éternellement
les pertes sont graves et il faudra donc
envisager un dépôt de bilan le ministère
vient de débloquer un fonds d'urgence
que je dirais pour pour améliorer
l'ordinaire mais il y à peu près de 200
millions de passif donc les éditeurs
vont trinquer
georges ghosn cette crise évidemment
passera est ce qu'il y a des solutions
est ce qu'il y a une voix futurs
possibles pour distribuer mieux la
presse en france dans les mois qui
arriveront ce genre d'avenir c'est bien
par trouver repreneur
mlp ont savent très bien géré donc ce
sont les repreneurs idéaux et qui se
financent et sapant cependant pas un
plan social et plus globalement réformes
et cette loi bichet et commencent à
s'interroger sur deux est fondée il ya
4000 titres et 25000 casse-cou surtout
est ce que vous êtes fondé à être
distribuée chez nous c'est la seule
bonne question
merci georges ghosn pour cet entretien
je rappelle vous êtes éditeur de presse
ancien propriétaire de france soir et du
nouvel économiste
pour conclure ce grand jt des
territoires comme chaque semaine ce sont
vos initiatives voest de solidarité ce
qui nous intéresse vous les exposés sur
les réseaux sociaux nous on aime bien et
regarder ça s'appelle le zapping des
solidarités proposés par nos confrères
de la boîte à histoires on regarde
ensemble
[Musique]
tout simplement parce que ça me fait
plaisir des personnels soignants sont
kizomba énormément coutume ça peut
apporter un jouet c'est parfait bonjour
hashtag les chefs avec les soignants on
est aux vertus gadahn en train de
préparer à manger pour l'hôpital de
creil et l'hôpital de chantilly et ce
week-end ainsi l'hôpital de beauvais un
agneau parce que c'est pas qui donc on
va faire de l'agneau et donc pour pas
que ç'a sûrement agneau est écrasée de
pommes de terre à la truffe avec un dos
dommage heures rappelez vous c'est
important de reconnaître le sont
c'est un don majeur et mineur sont tous
je chantais pour toi
[Musique]
voir voilà merci d'avoir suivi ce grand
jt des territoires on se retrouve pour
une nouvelle édition sur les chaînes
locales et régionales de la tnt et bien
sûr sur tv5 monde
bon courage à tous la très vite au
revoir
[Musique]